YES
YEEEEEEESSS
Finally
It finally happened.
My favourite channel.
MY FAVOURITE CHANNEL
Finally...
...did a video on me
I'm talking of course about...
WatchMojooo
If you don't know WatchMojo...
...thats like...
...you don't know Jesus.(really?)
WatchMojo: The Greatest Top 10 Channel...
...of all time
With such classic titles as:
Top 10 Anime Chefs
*Clap*
If you think I've been out of ideas...
...WatchMojo is on a whole new level of out-of-ideasness.
"Top 10 Greatest Sandwiches of All Time"
You can't beat that...
...you just CAAAAAAAAANNNNN"""""
""TTTT
"Top 10 Celebrities Who Tried to Hide Going Bald"
"Top 10 Unforgettable Anime Aliens"
*Laughs*
But now, the day I pray for has finally come...
"Top 10 Funniest Pewdiepie Videos"
*Sarcastic Clapping*
They did top 10, not top 3?
How did they manage top 10 of that?
Pffttt
That...uh...that's impossible.
How is it goin' bros
Uhhh...
*Groaning*
It's "How's it going sisters" okay?
Get it right
GET IT RIGHT DAMMIT, we're called sisters now.
Sister Fister™
Already...complete failure.
"Welcome to WatchMojo.com, and today we're counting down our picks for the top 10 funniest Pewdiepie videos."
I'm obviously a swedish person(duuh)
"Before we begin, we publish new videos every day, so be sure to subscribe for more great content."
Wait...no...wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You upload twelve videos a day.
*Laughter*
Do you want to get spammed with Top 10 videos?
Check it out:
"Number 10: Reading Mean Comments"
"As we all know, intense fame brings its fair share of critics."
Why are your headphones pink? Lol.
Number 9
What really? That's what they pick?
That's what they pick?
Funny montage 3
Number 8
Funny gaming montage?
Flappy Bird?
Happy Wheels?
Y'all nibbas just went to my top popular videos!
You didn't even watch my videos!
You just went to most popular!
And selected the what the fuuuuuuuuuck! (Lol)
Goddamn youuuuuuuu
Wait what is this--check out these related PewDiePie stuff (great grammar WatchMojo 10/10)
Ah you fuckers
Is that a referral link?
ITS A FOCKING REFERRAL LINK
YOU SNEAKY MOTHERFUCKEEEEERS
You know what? Fuck this, I'm going to make my own Top 10 video
It might be extremely self-absorbed, self-praising, self-loving, but that's who I am, baby,
And if you don't like it, then you can just
GO HOME
BIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIITCH!
Okay, I made a list
I made a list of top-
my favorite PewDiePie videos
If you haven't watched this, then you're not a real Sister Fister©, okay?
(Reading)
Comin' at you guys at number one...
YOUTUBE HIGH SCHOOL
"Today is my first day at high school."
"I can't believe I'm finally here..."
"I'm CUTIEPIEMARIZIA... and this is my story!"
*Shitty alternative rock music plays throughout*
I loved YouTube High School, it was like a 3 part series that I did (actually 5 parts)
Making fun of youtubers and youtube
*Sniffing noise* Ahhhhhh
It's extremely retarded
Extremely stupid
But that's sort of what made it funny
I think my favorite part of this is the soundeffect I did for when they walk
*PRRRRRT*
"Oh boy, that sure was a quick class...
"Pewdiepieeee!!!"
"Oh my god not this fucking idiot again..."
"PRT"
Ehh.. I wanted it to become like Youtube Highschool Musical
So I started making songs at the end of it
"Ooh, we shared all our secrets
"You know me in and out
But there is a detail I haven't told about
I'll let you slip it in the backdoor 3x
The backdoor
Still better than everyday bro at least
It really just became too much effort, cause people weren't watching it
Like, I know views isn't everything
And like I don't base all my decisions based on views
But the amount off effort these videos took
Compared to like how little views they got
It didn't seem like people really were into it
So... Ehhhh
I didn't really see a point of spending all that time
Like it would take me a day and a half at least to make
And I would like do nothing else
I'm not complaining, I'm just saying
I'm really proud of these videos
Uhh--because I really actually try to make something a bit more
But it just wasn't worth it
*laughs*
But moving on
Coming up at #2 guys
The falcon lover series
Yeah, does anyone remember these?
Back in 2014
People loved these
I think this is the first time I noticed people were like
"Well... wait PewDiePie doesn't just make retarded
horror videos screaming at them?
He actually makes funny stuff?"
I think these were those videos
For a lot of people.
Dear everyone. Please subscribe to my new channel, youtube.
I think I'm about to hit 3 subs soon.
Please subscribe and also please don't hate.
Peace!
It was basically--I
I don't remember what it was
I just made up this fuckin character
And wrote a story through the comments
Dear fans! Thanks for 5 subs!
I think it was inspired when I read hate comments
Based on a true story
Dear everyone,
Falcon lover here
I've come back to tell you all that
I've seen how you make funs of me
And I want you all to know that
Just because I don't to good quickscopes
And just because my montage doesn't have many views
That doesn't mean I don't have feelings
*laughs*
It kinda--it flows nicely.
I don't know. They're funny, if you wanna watch them
Umm... go right ahead
Alright guys
Coming up at top 3 everyone
Top 3 PewDiePie
*laughs* This is so s--this is so self centered.
Has anyone else on YouTube ever made a top 10 of your own videos?
So fuckin retarded, Jesus Christ
PewDiePie was--
Oh right, Ok, this one
This is my response video to my response video
It's kinda stupid.
When all the Wall Street Journal stuff went down
I had to make some sort of video addressing the situation seriously.
When in reality,
This is the video I wanted to make.
Basically just shitting on everyone. *laughs*
I thought it's solid
It's bulletproof
I go through everything very well
I articulated my points
In a way where you can't really dispute it
and I really didn't want to upload this video
Because I thought it would stir up more drama in the media
NO
Nope man
PLeasE
Say it's not true
Yes I heart on for the nazis.
NO!
NOoo
That's an anti-semitic joke.
-And not a single media
outlet posted about it. I'm-
*laughs*
They will take like- my update vlogs and make twenty articles-
like hundreds of articles about (like thousands of articles)
But this video --me adressing the media directly
and then they get away with that--
I think they can't really argue against.
Not a single-- not a single article
I'm not joking-- no one posted about it.
I remember- I posted it before the weekend and I was legit exhausted from all the dramas on the media
-and I was like "Fuck, I shouldn't uploaded this video cuz this gonna stir shit up"
Nothing.
Uh, I was legit amazed
I was like- "How is this possible?"
That no one is adressing this and then I was like--
"Oh yeah because it makes them look bad"
*laughs*
Don't get me wrong- I don't really care about all this stuff that happened anymore.
I'm not trying to bring up all drama but-- Uh,
I like the video
I think it is a good video and I'm proud of it.
Coming up at #4 everyone
Virtual Reality in public
This video was the fucking pain in the ass to film.
-I'm wearing aaaaa
Wireless VR headset
So I'm ready
I can jump around WHEREVER I want
Let's see... what wireless VR has to offer the future
LET'S GO
-Basically, we just went out in public
and I was pretending I was wearing- wearing a VR headset
HILARIOUS
-We got some some-uh-scrub-skateboarders over here
Can I skate with you guys?
Come on! (lemme skate)
-Oh yeah, they were IGNORING ME SO HARD
(Damn I got so much speed) That was so awkward
At the end there's fucking walking into the ocean
afterwards
Or like "-How do we end this shitty video?
-Uh
I'll just walking into the ocean!"
So fucking cold!
Not worth it
just not WORTH IT AT ALL
*chuckles*
I remember- *laughs*
I was just like BREATHE
*chuckles*
and think of the memes [same]
*laughs*
I remember going on like- *poods breathing in and out* [omg]
*laughs* [we're glad you're having a good time]
[where u going]
oh man
[goodbye merpoods, you'll be remembered]
Good times
This fucking video is not my favorite
but since I'm on the top they go fucking-
shit
Legit me falling here
I got a scar for life, okay?
Pokemon Go
is DANGEROUS
it ain't WORTH IT
don't do that shit
fuck YouTube and fuck Pokemon Go
moving on
Top #5 everyone
Can this video get 1 million *laughs* likes
Probably the easiest video we've ever shot
-U, BLIND?!
*Incredible recorder noise*
SMASH THAT LIKE, LIKE I SMASH MY FACE
[rip cardboard poods 2k17-2k17]
50 MILLION LIKES
*sprays holy water*
I just love the pure ADHD driven content
It's so fucking retarded
Coming up with top #6 everyone!
top #6
(Why are we still here)
Kazoo Kid
Kazoo KID
EVERYONEEEEEEE
(Every night)
(I can feel my leg)
(and my arm)
(even my fingers)
(the body I've lost)
Wait what was it?
(KAZOOOOOOOOOOO)
Jesus f*cking Christ
(Kazoooo)
it's good
It's good, it's good.
Coming up at top six everyone
My fovourite videos
I only like this video for two reasons
number one, this legit two second segment
(Roy kho coupah so)
(what the fuck does that mean *loud crash*
ow shit)
*pewds laughing*
fuckin hell, and of course Minaja Please (Renata Bliss).
(Hi I'm Renata Bliss, and I'm your freestyle dance teacher)
Top four everyone
I lost count...
I would have to say my response to Sorsha, it's so...
I think it's the first time I responded to
another Youtuber
Like I get a lot of videos like this
but I never actually bother... like I just ignore them
but I'm like ahh fuck it this is so stupid
I have to make a response.
what the, what the, what the, wwww
*ear rape* WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU DOING?
(Entertaining millions of people)
*pewds laughing*
What the fuck are you doing
I still love to quote that
it's just such a good meme
Coming in at top three
are you bored yet?
Cause it's about to get good.
BeastMaster Sixty-Four
the greatest
*pewds laughs*
This video legit we had no Idea
I owe this video to Brad cause like
we didn't know what the fuck to film.
Brad was like, "I'll save this video, we'll do this, and this, and this."
And I'm like ok lets do it
and...
I didn't think it would work,
but the video came out great.
That's a Pokemon!
That's a Pokemon right there!
Fucking Pokemon!
Brad: oh my god...
That's my Pokemon!
*gunshot from a crossbow...*
If Pokemon aren't real
then dogs aren't real either.
*pewds crying*
*pewds hyperventilating*
*another gunshot from a crossbow*
*pewds laughing*
It's my favorite ending of
any of my videos ever.
I love part two as well
cause legit I was terrified.
I thought I was gonna die.
I jum-
It was such a streamy day, like I...
I'm glad I wore the life vest
cause otherwise I would not have jumped
into the fucking water
tell the men...
remember me.
I remember swimming and I was just like
well...
I hope I make it to shore
*pewds laughing*
Like we ended up in such
a different location than
we started
it was so stupid.
My number one favorite video
is not even up on my channel anymore...
cause it got flagged for copyright.
It's so fucking retarded.
I bought this fucking car
I bought the cheapest car I could possibly find
just to make fun of people that flash...
just to make fun of YouTuber's that flash their car
We shot the video, we didnt think it was funny at all
but
it came out hilarious in the edit.
(3pac - Pewdiepie is a ...)
I still have the car
*pewds laughing*
Those are my top ten
What're your favorite
Pewdiepie videos!
NO!
NO, NO I have NO
There's no one of them
because their all shit
Thank you very much
Thank's for watching this one
I hope to make another
top ten favorites.
in the future.
Thank you guys so much
*kisses hand*
And as always
Sister Fister™!